[Música]
economía / auto américa de france 24 y
ya está conmigo en el estudio de los
méndez y dice bienvenido vamos a
entonces iniciar hablando de petróleo
porque esta materia prima abrió al alza
esta semana así que es raúl es una
situación que se produce luego de que de
acuerdo con los mercados el presidente
yo bailé no logró asegurar un aumento la
producción durante su visita a arabia
saudita el pasado fin de semana en
comparación con el pasado viernes 15 de
julio cuando los precios del barril
brent en cerraron la semana con un valor
por encima de los 100 dólares este lunes
se situaron a un poco más de 103 dólares
es decir un 24 por ciento por encima del
precio registrado el 15 de julio de
acuerdo con el ministro de relaciones
exteriores del reino de arabia saudita
el príncipe faisal team farhan al saud
en red la reunión del pasado fin de
semana poco se habló de la producción
petrolera y afirmó que continuarán
evaluando las condiciones del mercado
para establecer los precios vale decir
que el precio del petróleo registró un
leve descenso a mediados de la semana
pasada luego que los temor una recesión
global generaron expectativa en torno a
un menor consumo pero mientras los altos
precios del petróleo impactan de manera
negativa en algunas naciones debido a
entre otras cosas un aumento de la
inflación esto por los altos precios que
presenta la energía y también el precio
de los combustibles otros países tratan
de sacarle el mayor provecho a esta
situación es el caso de guyana país que
ostenta importantes reservas petroleras
y de gas que fueron descubiertas hace
aproximadamente unos 67 años atrás con
ello busca ahora acelerar los trámites
para explotar las reservas aunque esto
signifique sacrificar ganancias y
rentabilidad a largo plazo por que en
teoría tendrían que entregar la
explotación del producto petrolero a
empresas extranjeras recordemos que en
el 2015 cuando se descubrieron estos
yacimientos petroleros el plan de la
nación era explotar y operar casi la
totalidad del negocio para obtener una
mayor rentabilidad
louis seguimos hablando energía pero los
tomos europa por una escasez de gas de
cara el próximo invierno así que si es
que actualmente el almacenamiento de gas
se sitúa por debajo del 70% y se
desconoce si el bloque europeo podrá
cumplir con la cuota de almacenamiento
de un 90 por ciento establecida para el
mes de octubre el suministro de gas
vital para la obtención de energía en el
continente europeo ha sido la mayor
preocupación de gran parte de los países
de ese continente especialmente los que
pertenecen a la unión europea desde que
comenzó una guerra nuclear ya y
empezaron a establecerse las sanciones
en contra de rusia esto en parte han
estado orientadas a disminuir el ingreso
del kremlin por la venta de petróleo
pero ante esta situación diversos
líderes europeos entre ellos la
presidenta de la comisión europea han
visitado diversos países con el objetivo
de ganar de garantizar el suministro de
gas por ejemplo por su labor de ley está
en estos momentos en bakú azerbaiján
firmando acuerdos de suministro de gas
con esa nación algo similar lo hace el
mandatario o en este caso el primer
ministro mario draghi en él ya
entretanto el presidente francés
emmanuel mccrone firmó acuerdos para el
suministro de hidrocarburos a francia
con el nuevo líder de los emiratos
árabes unidos por otro lado de acuerdo
con la agencia de noticias ap el
suministro de casi las consecuencias que
ellos pueda generar sería el principal
problemas de europa en los actuales
momentos pero según la publicación rusia
podría presentar mayores problemas
económicos a futuro en parte por la poca
confianza de los inversionistas y
también la disminución del poder
adquisitivo de los ciudadanos rusos
los indicadores económicos las acciones
mundiales se han visto beneficiadas por
las ganancias que han mostrado a los
mercados chinos en este inicio de semana
luego que los reguladores instalarán a
los bancos a respaldar proyectos
inmobiliarios por ejemplo el hang seng
de hong kong registró un alza de 2.7 por
ciento en las operaciones de este lunes
con la noticia de que algunos proyectos
inmobiliarios se estarían reactivando
luego de encontrarse estancados debido a
otras situaciones por la pandemia
también los mercados europeos mostraron
números positivos a lo largo de sus
operaciones debido a esta situación que
se está presentando con el mercado hacia
cifra el día tiene que ver en este caso
con los 8500 millones de dólares que
según la publicación de clarín
registraría argentina en cuanto a sus
importaciones para el mes de junio este
es un dato que toma el clarín de acuerdo
con fuentes oficiales pero no del indec
está recordemos que está presentarse o
de confirmarse sería la mayor tasa en
las importaciones para esta nación de
sudamérica que superaría los 7 mil 800
millones de dólares que ya habían
registrado en el pasado pues louis como
siempre muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica nos vemos en
nuestra segunda obra de programa con más
economía y nos vamos directo hasta
londres para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal está pulido